So I just got back from the Matthew
McConaughey movie Serenity. Serenity 2019
I need to see normal movies again
because my sense of things has been
completely, completely and utterly broken
and and decalibrated. I want to say
people should see this movie. If you see
it without spoilers cool. If you see it
with spoilers cool. This is one of those
movies where like I didn't see a trailer
for it. I don't know how they marketed
this, like what they tried to market it
as and I really do want to go check that
out just because I am deeply curious
about how they, what they try to sell
this movie as. But based on the poster,
the poster is accurate for one of the
three movies that make up this movie.
Kinda. Yeah. Alright so this is kind of, a
lot of people were telling me to go see
this because it's like they were using
Book of Henry as a benchmark and I don't
fault them for that. Book of Henry is
actually a pretty decent benchmark for
you know like okay what is this thing
like. It's probably the most recent fair
comparison, though I would I would argue
Life Itself, but Life Itself actually
wound up having less of an impact than
people were expecting. But we're getting
a lot of these these days. How are all
of these getting green lit?
Like Book of Henry, Life Itself,
Serenity; so yeah I can see why people
are using Book of Henry as as their
benchmark, as their reference point for
this but the movie that this actually
reminded me of the most was The Beach
with Leonardo DiCaprio. And I don't
really blame people I don't I don't
fault people for not having you know
that reference right or right at the tip
of their brain because you know that
that movie's kind of... I don't want to say
that its forgotten but it's
definitely, it has not endured and not a
lot of people really strongly remember
it and new people aren't seeing it but
it shares a lot of similarities and if
you want to remain on support I mean
this is the thing this is the thing is
the moment that we're comparing it's
like well it's kind of like it reminds
me of the beach it's like book of Henry
I felt the same as I did during life
itself like these are already tells you
know it's just just by like referencing
these it's kind of given a bit of the
game away so yeah we're just gonna we're
just gonna go whole hog from now and and
just just get into it so this is three
different movies kinda smashed into the
same movie Radio Flyer
another solid comparison Wow Wow I need
to do something other than just compare
this to other movies that make you go
what was that I'm a little bit reluctant
to recommend it unlike book of Henry
book of Henry was one of those ones like
I got out of it and immediately it's
like no everybody go see book of Henry
everybody see book of Henry right now
because book of Henry is like beginning
to end just just a a wild
wild trip and this is not that this does
not have the same density of absurdity
as book of Henry which is why I would
say it's a little bit more like life
itself life itself was one that had like
a ton of absurdity at the beginning a
little bit at the end but for the most
part like and a lot of the ending
absurdity is you sitting there going
like looking at your watch being like
there's three minutes left water that
where is this going
where where as book of Henry is just
like this barrage few things will ever
quite rise to rise to that again so this
is not that and the - okay so the first
movie which kind of pairs well with the
second movie so the first movie that
makes this up is is a big fish movie
it's it's a it's a fishing gotta catch
the giant fish movie man versus nature
Moby Dick you know yeah the fish is
gonna be the fish is gonna be a metaphor
cool
the second movie is a noir Double
Indemnity kill my husband for me kind of
movie and you know a a Bigfoot a big
fish movie and a kill my husband movie
sure you can you can pair those together
I guess that's fine and then the third
movie is elephant or we need to talk
about kevin or Jerry or the beach
no the be okay so the beach comparison
is because video games play a prominent
side textual elements and just like the
beach they don't work well really
oh there's also dark city the matrix The
Truman Show there's there so there's a
lot going on here but there's also not a
lot going on this is part of the problem
this is actually this is actually a lot
of the problem
alright the the unfortunate thing is
that a lot of this movie is just kind of
dull it's it's not incompetently made
it's not you know what the fork is going
on
middling or middling got a catch a big
fish movie and and because it doesn't I
can't I can't talk about the problems
without just first talking about the
ending okay
so the movie has two component parts to
it the real world and the video game the
movie largest says the movie largely
takes place in a video game of nebulous
origin or I shouldn't say nebulous
origin a kid has made a video game as a
path of escapism to deal with his
abusive stepfather okay most of the
movie takes place in that video game
this doesn't really hold up very well I
I don't I I don't think the writer who
is also the director I don't think he
understands video games very well there
there's like sidelong references to sort
of like programmatic elements and rules
and you know the kind of like really
surface level trappings of like okay
somebody who understands that like
programs or programs and games are
programs and and understands a little
bit of the surface level trappings of a
videogame but does not actually like
play video games or understand how video
games work or anything like that because
once you start going through this and
like combing apart for like the actual
sort of use of the video game layer
metaphor it really falls apart because
it's super unclear like what's actually
going on so I'm I'm just going to have
to approach this on the movies own terms
and I need water so the kid has created
a video game version of a place called
Plymouth island that he and his father
visited when he was a kid and the video
game version is basically an open world
fishing game with a bunch of side
minigames that you can do as well but
there doesn't seem to actually be a
player Matthew McConaughey plays dill
and dill is in the computer game and is
a programmed version of the kids dad who
died in Iraq right okay okay wait wait a
thing I haven't even mentioned yet all
right so as part of the misdirection in
the noir part of the film is that Anne
Hathaway's character is talked
- Matthew McConaughey's character about
their son who is still back in Miami
living with abusive stepdad and as a
result of the abuse has like withdrawn
into himself and spends all his time
playing computer games and so this
element of the misdirection is set up as
that the the flashes to the kid playing
his video games are assumed to be in the
same space and timeline as Matthew
McConaughey but twists its back up to
the beginning now dill is trying to
catch a big tuna named justice and he's
slowly losing his mind and it's an
obsession Moby Dick blah all that then
then a femme fatale from his past life
walks into the bar and it switches into
a noir they used to be an item very very
new our standard they used to be an item
she wants him to make her husband
disappear because he's an abusive
he's an abusive piece of crap and she'll
pay him 10 million dollars to take him
out on his fishing boat and just make
him disappear you know you go out go out
into the middle of the ocean get him
good and drunk and then you catch a fish
and then oh no he slips overboard and
sharks eat him after that set up it then
just kinda spins its wheels for a while
until we get to the big reveal now
there's things peppered leading up to
the reveal so like dill can talk to his
son just sort of like there's a bunch of
magical realism sort of injected a bunch
of you know there's like a mystical
layer that just kind of keeps coming
back and there's a few shots that are
are very artificial and are deliberately
deliberately aping like the camera
angles and styles of video games the
ability for the camera to you know like
pivot around around the player character
and and stuff like that you know they're
they do foreshadow okay most of the
movie ends up being foreshadowing
because the story really is super simple
once you get past the like weird
trappings not much happens once the
conflict is set up nothing
really super changes even after the big
reveal and that's actually part of the
problem and what makes it really
confusing is that the information you're
not it doesn't actually change anything
and you're you're not you're not sure
what's supposed to be accomplished by
Dyl realizing he's part of a video game
and it he doesn't he doesn't rebelled
against it or I guess he sort of does
briefly for a little bit but not really
it's mostly just it's a pat out at the
time this is not a very long movie it's
definitely patting itself out in a bunch
of places just to kind of like get to
time there's a bunch of really
repetitive scenes with Anne Hathaway
where she just shows up and is like you
got to do it he's like I'm not gonna do
it got to do it I'm not gonna do it you
got to do it I'm not gonna do it you
gotta do it okay I guess I'll do it and
and then the moment he decides he's
gonna do it then it's just a bunch of
other characters and this ends up being
the like bulk of the con
flicked in like a big chunk of the movie
is just the other characters who are
also themselves part of the videogame
because they're all part of the video
game just being like you can't do it you
got to catch the fish instead you don't
kill that man so like they he goes out
one day and they catch a shark and he
doesn't kill them and you know this
isn't entirely incompetent lead unlike
there are moments you know it's like hey
attention and release and decent acting
it's just it's kind of pointless and not
moving very fast and the the the twists
along the way while it's in the war mode
like they're not very powerful they
don't really change anything they mostly
just stall for time and then the actual
core conflict of the kid versus his
stepfather is foreshadow 2-ton but it's
just for shadowed in the same way over
and over and over again with these
references to the knife and it's like so
with with these shots of a knife which
is the same so you're seeing the kid
play with the knife toy with the knife
and you're seeing dill also have a same
copy of the knife and and then at the
climax they go out into the boat so
margot robbie abusive husband dill and a
character that almost comes out of
nowhere as a last minute foil but this
character kind of comes out of nowhere
as a last-minute foil but he was
foreshadowed earlier so it it kind of
it's like oh you know that it that yeah
god okay so they get onto the
they're out on the boat they know
they're a video game or at least dill
knows he's a video game or as part of a
video game or as maybe the player avatar
in a video game I don't know but he is
the only one of them that knows the
Creator
oh yeah there's an entire so the scene
with neo and the architect in the Matrix
Reloaded there's basically a scene like
that sort of on the beach with this
mousy looking dude in a suit who
represents the rules and that's the
characters role like he constantly
refers to us I'm the rules oh right no
the conversation they have this whole
conversation about it's like nobody
knows the maker I know who the maker is
Matthew McConaughey mumbles 7/10 of his
lines I need more water they hook
justice they hook the tuna named justice
then they they they give it to the
asshole and hook them in and then like
go and he goes flying overboard and then
the kid in the real world so the shot is
monitor POV like it's even doing that
thing you know where they they overlay
text so let's you know so if I'm if I'm
dead center and I am typing at my
keyboard and then there's just there's
just text going up the screen so like
you're seeing you're seeing what's on
screen accepted backwards it's doing
that shot so it's doing that shot he
stops gets up takes the knife walks out
the door and then comes back in with a
blood-covered knife
and then it cuts back to the boat
and everybody's on the boat all happy
cuz the assholes dead and then the
camera pulls back into game footage and
then back from the monitor and you hear
newsreel over top telling you like the
real-world consequences of what just
happened
okay so it's like oh the kid got super
lost in his imagination in this game and
there's lots of like panning over you
know his his notebooks and stuff like
that and you know it's montage and
there's a really really bad D aged photo
of Matthew McConaughey dressed as a
troop and then here's where for me it
actually just went come so the very very
very very very very very very end so the
kid is in this very institutional
looking room and he's just staring dead
into the camera
he's just spiking the lens and you know
not blinking and the the news people are
still saying that it's like the kid
hasn't talked to anyone since the event
and then it goes back into it goes back
to Plymouth Island and Matthew
McConaughey stand next to it like he's
walking into a payphone the pay phone
rings he picks it up the to have a
conversation say hey dad is that you
yeah it's me okay
hey dad I'm changing the game so that we
can be together
special effects sequence were a whole
bunch of things kind of just like a
bunch of polygons fly around and things
kind of start deconstructing and
then they just reconstruct and then kid
runs down the pier to the boat named
serenity and leg jumps into his dad's
our jumps into Matthew McConaughey's I
was into deals arms and say yeah
and movies over okay so Matthew
McConaughey in the real world is dead so
there's two readings of this final shot
one is that the trauma of abuse and then
murdering his stepfather has basically
destroyed this kid forever and now he's
just he's just sunk eternally into his
mind and he now just lives in the
fantasy world that he is invented inside
himself or two he's now dead as well and
has killed himself
those are those are the two readings
that are implied by the ending of the
movie part of the problem is that
nothing about the videogame layer
actually matters at all it is the movie
Baker Dill's journey is the movie but at
the very end you're just told that Baker
dil isn't real and so and here's this
other thing that you're supposed to care
about more and it just it doesn't it
ends up landing in a very strange
intermediate place and also there's like
illusions and implications that this is
actually like the afterlife that oh man
I I really need to see it again to start
like decoding that take take it as you
will
I will say though I will go back to a
caveat like this I will say that this
movie is probably actually more
interesting to talk about than actually
watch it's a it's really interesting to
talk about but it is kind of dull on the
most part like it's not it's not that
bonkers
most of the time and a lot of the time
it's just kind of a like okay but
forgettable
you know genre drama with the occasional
weird stylistic flourish so so just in a
lot of ways it kind of seems like there
was this you know noir script that just
didn't it wasn't long enough and someone
decided to beef it up by adding this
twist and it got made this is one of the
strangest movies that I've seen in I
legit I legitimately for a large part of
this alright I guess this is the
unfortunate thing there's a plus and
minus here I did not know where this
movie was going which is usually a sign
of these like bonkers films it turned it
turns out that in the end I couldn't
really tell where it was going because
it wasn't really going anywhere it
really is a very very simple story once
it's disconnected from its ridiculous
conceits it is worth sitting through
absolutely everything else in this movie
purely to be witness to the end of this
movie even if you know it's coming it it
does not it does not do
justice to the experience of sitting
through it and and knowing the twist is
coming is just there's a texture to the
delivery of all of this that that cannot
be adequately communicated by a mere
review or vlog or or the the recitation
of a stranger you you need to sit
through it - really appreciate just how
weird and
delirious the ending is this is another
movie where it's like okay so this one
is actually you know metaphor dense
except it just like states all of its
metaphors very literally like characters
literally just explain what the
metaphors stand for even the really
blunt ones like of the tuna named
justice like a character just like it's
basically just explained like says like
yes the the tuna that the tunas name is
justice and you are getting justice as
you are being killed by the tuna named
justice this is justice it's a tuna
named justice do you get it the tuna is
named justice and the tuna is killing
you and it's name is justice you are
being killed by justice justice is
killing you now you are dead at the
hands of justice or well the fins of
justice the mighty fins of Justice it's
that kind of movie so it's it's worth it
for just seeing how like all of these
like all of these parts try to fit
together and and just just don't but
almost do but don't but they almost do
but they don't but but almost but no but
maybe but almost but they don't but they
kinda do anyway that was a ride
serenity twenty nineteen twenty nineteen
is already off to just wild year wild
year for anything can happen who knows
what's coming next
I've got I've got no idea movies can
actually surprise me again